attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
attends attends c'est exactement ce que
tu crois on à kent au bout de deux
vertus sais je parle à tout le monde et
là j'ai parlé à brune et on n'a pas fait
que parler
qu'est ce que fout casse toi non au
début j'étais pas très intéressé et puis
au bout de deux trois verres là commence
à me chauffer et puis là je me suis dit
pourquoi pas donc nous deux c'est fini
ah bah vous deux ça sent pas bon non on
va voir parce qu'à mon avis je vais
avoir un premier mois très intenses avec
bruno et tu as vu chez lui à nos abonnés
vexé mes parents qui sont conscientes
les accus
je garde la partie et en peluche désolé
métier qu'est ce qu'il est rouvert
mais j'ai eu un orgasme et du premier
coup commenté fait écouter un coup de
chance
franchement je sais projet appuyé mais
alors geyser de plaisir bon moi j'aime
faire les yeux qui échoue pour une
honnête non non mais qu ils seront chez
eux attendant ma meuf on n'a pas eu ça
va oui j'aimerais qu'on se bat sinon la
porte du frigo côté du beurre bon
évidemment je souhaite pas d'être
heureux qui met bien les trois fillettes
parce qu'au début tu vas voir ses
dentelles et nuisettes et puis sa fille
et en jogging la bouche un homme est
inquiète pas moi je comptais l'avoir de
trois fois histoire de marquer le coup
sûr mais après je pense que ça ira pas
plus loin
toi je te déteste un joli après si tu
m'appelles je peux revenir direct non ça
n'arrivera pas messieurs allez salut
ciao bello bail
c'est déjà fini et équité alors je vais
acheter des oeufs type 2
[Musique]